[Music]
for most of history
humans had no idea what purpose the
heart served
in fact the organs so confused leonardo
da vinci
that he gave up studying it although
everyone could feel their own heart
beating
it wasn't always clear what each thump
was achieving
now we know that the heart pumps blood
but that fact wasn't always obvious
because if a heart was exposed or taken
out the body would perish quickly
it's also impossible to see through the
blood vessels
and even if that were possible the blood
itself is opaque
making it difficult to see the heart
valves working
even in the 21st century only a few
people in surgery teams
have actually seen a working heart
internet searches for heart function
point to crude models diagrams or
animations that don't really show how it
works
it's as if there has been a
centuries-old conspiracy amongst
teachers and students
to accept that heart function cannot be
demonstrated
meaning that the next best thing is
simply to cut it open
and label the parts that way students
might not fully grasp the way it works
but can superficially understand it
learning such concepts as
the heart is a four chambered organ or
potentially misleading statements like
mammals have a dual circulation one with
blood going to the lungs and back
and another to the body and back in
reality
mammals have a figure eight circulation
blood goes from one heart pump to the
lungs
back to the second heart pump which
sends it to the body
and then back to the first pump that's
an important difference
because it marks two completely
different morphologies
this confusion makes many students wary
of the heart in biology lessons
thinking it signals an intimidating
subject full of complicated names and
diagrams
only those who end up studying medicine
completely understand
how it all actually works that's when
its functions become apparent
as medics get to observe the motion of
the heart's valves
so let's imagine you're a medic for a
day
what you'll need to get started is a
whole fresh heart
like one from a sheep or pig immerse
this heart in water
and you'll see that it doesn't pump when
squeezed by hand
that's because water doesn't enter the
heart cleanly enough for the pumping
mechanism to work
we can solve this problem in an
extraordinarily simple way
simply identify the two atria and cut
them off
trimming them down to the tops of the
ventricles this makes the heart look
less complicated because the atria have
several incoming veins attached
so without them there the only vessels
remaining are the two major heart
arteries
the aorta and pulmonary artery which
rise like white columns from between the
ventricles
it looks and really is very simple
if you run water into the right
ventricle from a tap
the left also works but less
spectacularly you'll see that the
ventricular valve
tries to close against the incoming
stream and the ventricle
inflates with water squeeze the
ventricle and a stream of water squirts
out of the pulmonary artery
the ventricular valves called the
tricuspid in the right ventricle
and the mitral in the left can be seen
through the clear water
opening and closing like parachutes as
the ventricle is rhythmically squeezed
this flow of water mimics the flow of
blood in life
the valves are completely efficient
you'll notice they don't leak at
all when the ventricles are squeezed
over time they also
close against each other with very
little wear and tear
which explains how this mechanism
continues to work seamlessly
for more than two billion beats a heart
gives in its lifetime
now anyone studying the heart can hold
one in their hands
make it pump for real and watch the
action unfold
so place your hand above your own and
feel its rhythmic beat
understanding how this dependable inner
pump works gives new resonance to the
feeling you get when you run a race
drink too much caffeine or catch the eye
of the one you love
[Music]
you